Okay let me get back to where I was.
Okay, so we declared the two variables, and then there's two print lines
the first one >> Excuse me did, did the recorder correct the comments?
To make, make note of the errors in the comments that,
that >> Slash asterisk should our new standard coding as well.
>> Yeah these easier being pointed out, that we should be,
it's said that they're characters but they were declared as integers.
>> For int next, it says next character is that it?
>> Yeah. >> Put a line through.
>> The implication is that you're confused about characters versus integers.
>> Mm-hm, even though the representation was also signed.
>> Okay so as I was saying there is two print statement,
the first one prints to the user, enter a sentence ending with a period, and
the second one says, follow each character buy a return.
>> We have a typo.
>> Yeah, I guess, buy should not really be buy, >> And
also probably, follow, should be capitalized, right?
I mean it's a separate sentence so
you're trying to [COUGH] write it as a sentence.
>> Or it should be all on one line, because you're,
you're breaking at interest and it's ending with a period oh, okay, I see.
>> But it also, it's interesting,
Interest in it is ending with a period doesn't have a delimiter at
the end where it's follow each character by a return does have a delimiter.
>> Should that be, have a colon there?
>> It seems like we're really getting stuck on minor details.
>> I think so too, let's move on, let's move on back to Dr.
Bug, please continue.
>> So a character is, misspelled.
>> It's charcter.
>> Just making, I think it's making for bad user experience, we don't, we don't,
you know >> Yeah, actually I think I was just copy and
paste in here from someone elses code, but that's fine.
Yeah, I think it's. [LAUGH] >> Is that what we do now?
Is we copy, copy from other people's [CROSSTALK].
>> Well, it's just this, you know?
This was [CROSSTALK].
>> Whose was it that we copied from?
>> It was part of a log, I mean, I think it was actually Crazy Bob's code, but
[LAUGH] I could be wrong.
>> It wasn't my code because it's not in native.
[LAUGH] >> Yeah. >> It was a native piece of code.
>> In fact, if we could just back go back and revisit, 13 and
14, you know, this initialization problem wouldn't even be
occurring because you can't have uninitialized data in aid.
So if we'd actually done what we said,
what I said originally, we wouldn't be having these problems.
>> You, you're absolutely right, I forgot about that.
Crazy Bob bring,
brings up some excellent points, about this lousy code we're looking at.
>> I have to say, actually, I'm pretty sure that in Java, when you
declare a lock of variable like this, it gets initialized automatically to zero.
But I might be wrong.
>> That's the instance variables that are initialized, and
the local variables are not initialized.
>> Okay, maybe I'm wrong then >> Even if there are automatically initialized,
good code behavior would be that you actually initialize them so
everybody doesn't have to remember whether it works or not.
>> Well, just, you know, I was used to developing data, so that's reality.
>> Yeah [LAUGH].
>> Okay, let us continue Dr. Bug.